[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
السلام عليكم
يعني
في البدايه انا سعيد جدا ان انا موجود
معكم النهارده
ان انا جيت بعده دكتور حازم فمش عارف اقول
ايه
انا بشكره طبعا انا استفدت جدا من العرض
القيم
بشكر طبعا فريق درايه بشكر دكتور احمد
وبشكر من كل القائمين على التنظيم يمكن
انا حاسس ان انا جيت من الاخر فانتم اكيد
ان شاء الله مش هتكلم كتير انا حتى يعني
يمكن تقديرا لكم
مخلل الحوار النهارده هيبقى حوار من القلب
للقلب زي ما بيقولوا كده
حوار مفتوح شويه ما جهزتش وانا متعمد
لكل الموضوع حتى
يكمل الجزء بتاع دكتور حازم
فكره نجاح
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
اللي هي احيانا ما بتبقاش لها علاقه
بالتخصص لكن قد يكون
الناظر لها على ان هي نجاحات بيقيمها من
ناحيه مختلفه شويه اللي هي تقييم شهره
تقييم مادي تقييم وهذا هو نجاح لكن في
الحقيقه النجاح الحقيقي للشخص اللي هو
يقدر يستغل طاقته الذهنيه يقدر يستغل
طاقته المعرفيه يقدر يستغل تخصصه
وممارسته بالمهنيه ويقدر ينشرها ويقدر
يفيد بها بمجتمع وهذا هو العلم النافع
في الحقيقه
موضوع نجاح مش مرتبط فقط بالقدره العقليه
ولذلك انا هتكلم عن حاجتين الفكر
والنهارده هقرب منكم انتم شويه مش هخش في
مواضيع جانبيه او حاجات من هذا الطبيب لكن
الجيل بتاعكم او الجيل بتاعنا
وكل الاديان صراع القائم بين العقل
والعاطف
واحنا امتى بنلتقي وامتى بنقدر ان احنا
ناخد فراغات صعود صائبه
وامتى بيكون التاثير الاكبر
بالدماغ وانت بيكون التاثير الاكبر للالف
والعواطف والمشاعر
المعروفه عندكم في مجال الطب عموما انا بس
بصلح وتعالي عشان ما بحبش اخد حاجه مش
بتاعتي
انا
استاذ علم النفس والعلاج النفسي
ومش طبيب نفسي عشان بس المفاهيم طبعا
عارفين الكلام ده انا حتى ما عرفتش نفسي
لاني كلكم جامعه قرايه فاكيد عارفيني رئيس
قسم العلوم الانسانيه هنا في الجامعه
والمدير مركز الارشاد النفسي في جامعه
جرايه
اصلا قسم علم النفس كليه الاداب جامعه
الفكره اللي هي واحنا بنرتقي مع الوقت
بتيجي عندنا
ندبات نفسيه كتيره جدا جدا لان كل يوم
لاذى في المشاعر وهذا في العلاقات
وبالتالي انا عايز نبص للاموره على زي ما
احنا بنبص في مجال الطب
الناس اللي عندها مشاكل او ظروف
مرضيه طارئه بيحتاج والحاجه اسمها
الاسعافات الاوليه احنا ايضا في مجال علم
النفس محتاجين ده جدا جدا جدا
ازاي ان احنا نعمل اسعافات
متعلقه بالجانب النفسي وسريعه لمشاكلنا
خاصه
بتخصكم مرحله العمريه بتاعتكم دلوقتي اللي
هي متعلقه بالمشاعر
والعواطي
التخلي
العلاقات السامه العلاقات المزعجه
الحب الفشل مش عارف ايه كل الحاجات اللي
احنا رحنا مش هنحط رسمه في الارض ونقول
انها مش موجوده بالعكس انا شايف ان لو
الامور دي
مشيت معنا من صغرنا واحنا ماشيين بشكل كده
في استقرار واتزان عاطفي وجداني في تفاعل
ما بين الفكر والوجدان والسلوك الدنيا
هتتضبط لان اللي بيعمل لنا خلل دايما او
يفشلنا مرتبط بالنجاح هو ان انا مبقدرش
اعمل توازن بين افكاري وطريقه تفكيري
والعقليه اللي انا موجود بيها من الاول
والمشاعر اللي بتتاثر بطريقه تفكيري وفي
نفس الوقت الناتج بتاعها والتصرفات
التصرفات هو تعدي هي القياس النجاح يعني
بقعد بقدر اقول على شخص ان هو ناجح او
فاشل من خلال تصرف اته واداءاته الموجوده
في دراسته في شغله في مهنته وبعد كده في
انتشاره في المجتمع في الناس دي كلها
عمليه مرتبطه لبعضيها البعض طيب احنا
ليه بنقول كده ليه بنقول ان في علاقه بين
الفكر والعاطفه والسلوك
لان لو انا بفكر بشكل منطقي
هيتمنى مشاعر
مستقره هاديه ما فيهاش مبالغه ما فيهاش
حزن ما فيهاش اكتئاب ما فيهاش شعور ضمير
ما فيهاش شعور كل الحاجات اللي ممكن تؤثر
سلبا على
سلوكياتي بعد كده لو انا بتبنى افكار
سلبيه وغير منطقيه واقول انا مش هقدر انا
ما عنديش القدرات انا منحوس انا حظي وحش
ما هي البيئه قافله عليا انا مش قادر اعمل
حاجه انا عندي هدف واحد مش قادر احط اهداف
تانيه
الظروف والضغوط الجامعه ايه الامكانيات
الماديه
او عوق
ات اللي في الدنيا يحط لسته كبيره جدا جدا
جدا منها هي الحاجات دي احمر ما نقدرش
نغير
استراس موجود في كل وقت لكن انا عايز
اغيرك انت
عايز اغير طريقه تفكيرك ازاي انك انت تقدر
تعمل
الامور دي كلها وتقدر تبقى معاها متكيف
معاها تقدر تغيرها بالاحسن عشان تبقى جزء
من طاقتك الايجابيه اللي بتخليك قادر طيب
القلب المسيطر علينا اكثر ولا سؤال بقى بس
نجاوب بصراحه
في المرحله بتاعتكم دلوقتي القلب ولا
العقل ولا العين
[موسيقى]
انا حبيت نتكلم كده يعني انا يعني ناخد
وقتنا ولو عايزين نقول اي حاجه
ايه مش عارفين مسيطر عليكم اكتر هنا يعني
لو
اقول ايه
لو هتختلط تدرسي علاج طبيعي بلاش اقوله
هتختاري تدرسي علاج طبيعي اخترت علاج
طبيعي عشان حبه مهنه العلاج الطبيعي
قريب ومش عارف مين وماما وبابا
عملوا شكل من الاشكال
قبل مفهوم العلاج الطبيعي من
غير حتى بتنزل بتاعته هي وانت هتشتغل ايه
او التفاصيل بتاعته هتكون ايه ولا انت
حابه مجال الشغل ده عشان انت فكرتي وشفتي
نماذج
وعارفه طبيعه الدراسه وعارفه طبيعه
الجامعه وجايه وحبه ده بالفعل او عن وجبه
كرام المعرفي الذهني من البدايه قبل ما
يكون فيه خير او عاطفه ناحيه الحاجه معينه
ده انا بتكلم احنا حياتنا اليوميه
ماشيه بالطريقه دي احنا طول الوقت في حاله
عركه بالبلدي كده بين العقد والعاطف هعمل
ده وانا مقتنعه به ولا هعمله عشان انا
حباك
تمام دي حاجه الحاجه التانيه اللي هو
بيخلي ده الصراع بيننا وبين الاهل والناس
اللي حوالينا والمجتمع
هل انا متوافق على المستوى الشخصي
ولا متوافق على مستوى الاجتماعي لحته برضو
لازم افكر فيها اللي انا بعمله ده قضيني
وحرق وانا حبه وبوستني ايا كان
على هوايا على مزاجي وفقا لمشاعري وفقا
ولا انا ببص
للرولز والبعير والمج
تمع والقانون والدين والاخلاق والتربيه
والثقافه وكل حاجه حتى في الاعتبار عشان
كده باخد قرارات وفقا لهذا الامر
غالبا اول حاجه
او ان انا الاقي نفسي لما بتعرض لموقف
فشل
وتجارب ده ليه لان يمكن ده بطبيع الشغلانه
كل يوم
بنلاقي ان ممكن مشكلات اكاديميه بتاعتكم
او قرارات تتعلق بالشغل حتى بعد كده او
قرارات مصريه في الحياه تكون
متاثره بشكل كبير جدا جدا بمشاكل انفعاليه
فكره اهلي عني شايفين وحشه يا دكتور دايما
يقولوا لي انا ما بقدرش اعمل حاجه ومش
هنجح في حاجه وهم كل همهم يدوني فلوس بس
في النهايه مش مش مدركين مش داخلين جوايا
ومش عارفين انا بفكر فيه ومش حاسه بيه ما
حدش بيحس بيا دي مشاعر تمام
جيت سنه اولى كليه وثانيه كليه وتالته
كليه ودخلت في علاقات ما كنتش مجهز نفسي
نفسيا ان انا اخشها
عرفت ان في حاجه اسمها حب وعواطف ومش عايز
فدخلت في علاقات رومانسيه وحاجات من هذا
الطبيب وهي اصلا علميا انت لسه لم ترتقي
بعد وفقا للدراسات العلميه بتقعد لحد 21
22 23 سنه يعني اللي هي نهايه مرحله
المراهقه
وانت مش مدرك ان انت لسه ما تعرفش تاخد
قرار عاطفي
فبتيجي تلاقي خبرات سلبيه بتاذي المشاعر
وممكن تكون معوقات من ضمن المعوقات اللي
هي بتحصل معنا ونيجي نقول احنا اتاذينا
احنا اتكسرنا احنا اصل جراح اصلا مش عارف
ايه وبعدين مش عارفين ان احنا مش عارفين
نكمل مش عارفين نشوف دراستنا
ونعلق في شماعات على المشاكل اللي احنا
مسؤولين عنها لان احنا ما اخدناش القرار
التوازن بين العاطفه
والقرار المنطقي اللي انا ممكن اخده بعقلي
واشوف هينفع ولا مش هينفع ايه بيحصل امتى
بيحصل مع الارتقاء العمري بتاعنا في مرحله
رابعه خامسه جامعه او يعني المراحل
النهائيه من الجامعه الواحد يكون مر
الاختبارات اكتر ومش شايف ظروف حياتيه
اكتر وشاف تجارب الاخرين ويقدر في الحاله
دي يقرر بالفعل الطلاق سواء كان نابع من
القلب من العهد بيكون قرار منطقي وسائط
الى حد كبير
طيب افتراضنا ده حصل وبرده اتعرضنا لهذا
مشاعر او مشاعر افضل او مشاعر
ده بياثر على حاجه مهمه جدا جدا
تمثل جهاز المناعه
اللي هي تقدير الذاتي انا لو حسيت ان انا
قليل دنيتي هتبوظ كل واحد فينا كده كل
واحد دايما لازم يبقى واعي بنفسه يعني ايه
قالها دكتور حازم اللي هي انا عارف
مهاراتي وعارف امكانياتي وعارف قدراتي
وعارف كل حاجه
عن خصائصي وكل حاجه في الشخصيه دي كلها
عشر مسؤوله عن ان انا اكمل ولا لا الوعي
بالذات اللي هو بيخليني ماسك المسطره بتاع
تك لان لو زادت
الجسمانيتي وشغلانه تانيه هتبقى مشكله
كبيره جدا لو قلت
هخش في مرحله سيئه جدا جدا
مفهوم ذات سلبي تمام لكن المفروض ابقى
عامل شكل من اشكال التوازن ماسك المسطره
في النص بالظبط وبتزيد بتقل احيانا على
حسب الظروف وعلى حسب المواقف ومع اختلاف
الناس واختلاف المعاملات
الواحد يجي يقول لي يا دكتور
معين هو
فانا عشان عندي تقدير لزائد لذاتي طبيعي
وسوي اقول له شكرا بس انا لما اقول له
شكرا مش هبقى فرحان قوي ان هو قال لي كده
ليه لان انا مدرك
امكانياتي وعارف ان هو بيجاملني وعارف ان
هو بيقول لي حاجه مش في اصلا
تمام فدي مساله مهمه جدا جدا واحد تاني ما
بيحبنيش قوي يجي يقول لك والله بص انا
شايفك حد متكبر وتعالي وهي بتتعامل مع
الناس برجرافه مش عارف ايه اقول له شكرا
برضو نفس الطريقه في المعامله هي هي ليه
مش همسك في دماغ
ه انا فاهم نفسي فانا هقول له شكرا بس انا
مش
خلاص خلاص هو ده تقدير الذات المظبوط احنا
مشاكل
ولا دكتور او دكتوره يعني
اصل الزمالك
في السكن مش عارف اقعد يقولوا لي ماما في
البيت كمان واحده عارفاني عارفه
وبتقول لي انت مش فالحه
وانت واحيانا بيبقى الموضوع مرتبط بيه
كله مفهوم ازاي بقى سواء كان جسد او الذات
الريال بتاعتي او السوشيال سيلفي بتاعتي
او اي سيلفي بتاعتي اللي انا بتمناها ما
احنا مش عارفين احنا عايشين بايه هو احنا
عايشين بالذات المثاليه
ولا عايشين بالذات الواقعيه اللي احنا
بنتصرف من خلالها فعلا
كتير مننا جدا بيمشي بالطريقه المزيفه هو
حقيقته ايه هو طبيعته ايه هو تركيبته
النفسيه ايه هي دي الذات اللي بنسميها
بتاعتك بالذات الواقعيه بتاعتك تصرفاتك
الحقيقيه اللي بتاعك الشخصيتك الحقيقيه
فدائما بقول لاي حد هديك كده خليك حقيقي
زي ما انت ما تزينش لكن تمنى من باب الوسط
انك تقصد الى
اللي هي الزيات الميزانيه وليكن هتحاول
هتبقى احسن لان هتدي لك دفعات قويه جدا
للنجاح زي ما قال دكتور حازم تمام لكن
برضو في اعتبارك
تصرفاتك مع الناس
هتتقد سلوكيات معينه لو كانت هذه الس
مستهجئه
بالثقافه المجتمع اللي انت موجود فيه ودي
حته مهمه لاني انا مش هعيش لوحدي انا عايش
وسط ناس ما ينفعش ابقى في جامعه
اتصرف تصرفات او اغلاف المكان اللي انا
موجود فيه يبقى انا هنا ممكن ابقى عملت
حاجه عجباني لكن مش متصله مع المعايير
الاجتماعيه اللي بتخلينا نعمل ده فاول اذى
نفسي بيجينا من العلاقات السامه دي او من
المشاكل اللي فيها حد فيها تنمر او فيها
ترك او فيها فشل او ان انا ممكن مفهومي او
تقدير الذاتي يقل ولو قل زي ما قلنا هتبقى
مشكله هتخش في مشاكل نفسيه خطيره جدا
ولو مع الوقت انا ضخمت ده زياده عن اللزوم
برده هخش في مشاكل وبالتالي الموضوع صعب
جدا الحاجه التانيه عشان ما اطولش عليكم
احنا دايما
اسمها
او الحوار الشخصي
اللي جوانا احنا كلنا دلوقتي واحنا قاعدين
بنتكلم من جوه
كلنا بنعمل حوار شخصي واحنا قاعدين بنتكلم
نفسنا احنا مش مجانين مش مجانين يعني
مجانين لا هو كده
[ضحك]
كل ما كانت حواراتك الداخليه او حديثك
لنفسك حديث ايجابي
وبيدي لك طاقه ايجابيه وكله
كل
ما قادر على التكيف مع كل الظروف السهره
اللي انت تتعرض لها شايف نفسك في صورتك
الحقيقيه
وهيحسن من مستوى الصحه والنفسيه بتاعتك
ومش هيخليك تخش في حته
مع ان الشعور بالذنب حاجه جميله جدا
عشان بس الناس بتغلط في المفاهيم يقول لك
يا دكتور انا طول الوقت
طبيعي جدا
ده حقك ومن باب
بنسميها احنا الشفافيه مع النفس او انت
صالح مع النفس انك تيجي في اخر يوم
وتطلب لك وانت لو مشيت كده اعتباطا يبقى
انت مش هتصوب
ما احنا مفيش مش ملائكه ولا الناجحين ولا
الناس المتميزت قوي اللي احنا شايفينها
المجتمع واو دي ناجحه بالمعنى الحقيقي زي
ما بقول لو كل واحد عمل وهو نفسه الدكتور
حسن مهمه جدا رغم كل النجاح اللي انا
هاخده ده كله انا حاسس من جوايا ان انا ما
عملتش حاجه هو احساس شخص ده بايجابي بقى
لانه بيدفعه لقدام هو طول الوقت لو صدق
نفسه انه وصل للقمه مش
هيعمل حاجه تمام يبقى الحوار السلبي ده
ممنوع زائد ان انا الوم نفسي في الاوقات
التي تستحق اللون والمحاسبه فقط لا غير
لكن ما بقاش طول الوقت بعمل ده
تعميم من نفسي اطيق يعني ممكن ما تبقاش
اسباني حاجه خارجه حاجه قدريه
حاجه حقيقيه فعلا وانا لازم اعترف بوجودها
واقعدش بقى طول الوقت
فاصل الى درجه من الدرجات
الانعزاليه مش هبقى عارف اتعامل مع الناس
وشايف نفسي في في صوره فيها
او شعور بالنقص طول الوقت اقل من ايه
وبالتالي هحس دايما للخشب في النهايه عشان
ما اطولش عليكم احنا محتاجين لاول
الاسعافات نفسيا لو لنفسنا ماشي كده ورجلي
اتلوت وانا ماشي على السلم
طيب
وجيب طلع السلم التاني رحت وقعت رجلي
الاول اللاويه دي اقدر انا اتعامل معها
ولا ما اقدرش اتعامل معها انا كشخص بسيطه
النكبه البسيطه دي اقدر اتعامل معها كشخص
اه اقدر اتعامل معها كشخص او اشوف حد من
المحيطين يساعدني يعدل رجلي عادي جدا لكن
لو انتصرت لازم اروح لدكتور متخصص بتاع
جراحه عظام وبعد كده بقى لك طبيعي وحاجات
بتاعتكم
دي كلها صح
هو ده اللي انا بقوله لو عندك مشاكل نفسيه
خفيفه تقدر تحلها مع نفسك تعمل
غير
بيتك السلبيه بقدر الامكان هتاخد جهد تاخد
وقت خليك دايما بتفكر بايجابيه حط السمات
الايجابيه في الشخصيه
قدامك طول الوقت انك انت تبقى جزء في
تركيبتك وبعدين لو لقيت دي بتكبر ما ينفعش
انك انت تفتي لا لازم ترجع
للمتخصص عشان يساعدك في حل مشاكلك
بالنهايه بشكركم وانا بعبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]